hillary clinton is using 911 to trash
republicans humpty dumpty has a big new
job teaching your children and democrat
karen bass who rails against your second
amendment rights just lost track of her
own guns but first we are only 57 days
away from this tipping point midterm
election the housing market is on the
verge of collapse inflation is at a
40-plus year high we have been in a
recession for months and months and
months the southern border is in a state
of chaos violent crime is spiking all
over the country fentanyl deaths they
too are at an all-time high so now with
the midterms around the corner democrats
want you to forget all about this
instead they want you to focus on only
three main distractions here's their
game plan for the next 57 days they are
attempting to divide the country on the
basis of race and gender and age etc
it's their usual playbook their election
year playbook or election year lie
depending on how you uh want to
characterize it republicans are racist
sexist homophobic xenophobic
islamophobic they want dirty air water
you know the routine second democrats
want to gin up hysteria around abortion
and yet another lie they will attempt to
scare voters by claiming that abortion
is illegal that simply is not true after
the dobbs ruling abortion is still very
much legal in the vast majority of
states and i have it on good authority
that republicans in the senate will
bring up a national abortion law
sometime this week that would have a
mandate of time of 15 weeks which is
what the mississippi law called for and
that brings us to their third
distraction as we speak democrats are
trying to dehumanize and vilify quote
those evil
rascally mega republicans and donald
trump supporters in order to rally their
base according to biden and other
democrats half of america is now a
threat to democracy simply because they
now support or once supported donald
trump so instead of trying to fix the
economy or dare talk about it or the
border or the fentanyl fentanyl or
opioid crisis or the crime crisis
democrats have been wasting almost all
of their time and billions of your tax
dollars with one investigation after
investigation into all things donald
trump and this has been going on now for
years first it was the russia hoax and
it was comey's crossfire hurricane
mueller's witch hunt the emoluments
clause investigation from the house
oversight committee a house ways and
means investigation into trump's taxes
another house investigation into trump's
hotel lease another house investigation
into foreign gift disclosures a d.c
probe in the trump's inauguration
fundraising another similar
investigation from the southern district
of new york and the eastern district of
new york and from new jersey's attorney
general one impeachment investigation
into a regular phone call with ukraine a
second impeachment investigation into
january 6 yet another house committee
investigation into january 6th that is
still ongoing with more hearings to come
and then there's the southern district
of new york's investigation into pardons
a doj probe into trump's political
action committee another house
investigation into the trump
administration's security clearance
process other investigations into
trump's property valuations and of
course the social media truth social the
trump foundation as well as a variety of
other tax investigations and of course
the national archives investigation that
led to the mar-a-lago raid you got all
that we'll ask you at the end of the
show if you remember after all of this
trump has not been charged with any
crime whatsoever and they're trying hard
but there's been nothing that's because
the partisan democrats in charge of all
of these witch hunts they're not
investigating crimes they're
investigating a person in a blatant
attempt to smear slander destroy him and
destroy his supporters the old soviet
union saying show me the man i'll find
you a crime except they haven't actually
found a crime yet so i guess they'll
make that up too so do not take debate
for the next 57 days do not get
distracted democrats they'll call you
semi-fascists they're the ones who stop
your kids from going to school for two
years they're the ones who fired you if
you refused to vaccine they're the ones
that blocked you from going to church
during covent they're the ones who hired
87 000 new irs agents to audit you and
every small business in the country
they're the ones who caused inflation
with record high spending they're the
ones who are blocking the production of
oil gas and energy independence in this
country they're the ones who are
emptying out our prisons they're the
ones that support defunding and
dismantling police departments they're
the ones that want to end all cash bail
and making all of our communities less
safe republicans on the other hand are
now offering
a new contract with america they're
calling it commitments to america this
will be out in the next two weeks what
they stand for what their vision for the
future of this country is lower taxes
less bureaucracy fewer regulations
energy independence law and order so we
can be safe and secure
border security schools that actually
teach reading writing math science
history and computers and not crt and
social justice and gender identity
congressional republicans are also
vowing to conduct real oversight with
investigations into the fba the
fda the cdc the irs the doj the fbi and
the entire biden administration this
will reverse itself now this election is
about restoring sanity and common sense
to government a time when our president
has lost touch with both uh of these
realities if he's even aware that today
is monday take a look it's frustrating
it's inconvenient
and it's bad for the environment and
there's simply no reason for it
this is the united states khmer for
god's sake
this is who we are this is not this is
not what we should be doing hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else